هذه هي قريه كميانكا الاوكرانيه التي عاد
اليها السكان بعد خروج القوات الروسيه
العيش هنا اصبح شبه مستحيل في ظل تساقط
الامطار الجليديه ودرجه الحراره التي لا
تتجاوز الصفر بما ان ترميم المنازل يتطلب
الكثير من الوقت قررت اولجا ان تجمع على
الاقل ما تبقى من الحبوب في مخزنها المدمر
على ما يبدو القي الجنود الروس قنبله
يدويه وافسد محاصيلنا والاتنا الزراعيه
كانت هذه الحبوب توزع على المنطقه باسرها
على زوجي الان ان يشتري الالات زراعيه
جديده في منطقه الكاف اعيد التيار
الكهربائي الى 70% من المنازل رغم ذلك
يفضل هؤلاء الاوكرانيون البقاء من دون
كهرباء على الاحتلال الروسي
يجب ان تتوقف الحرب بطريقه ما روسيا هي من
حاولت احتلال اوكرانيا يجب ايقافها لكي
ننعم بالسلامه
تفعل بمنظمه الصحه العالميه الى التحذير
من تداعياتها المميته بسبب البرد القارس